[Música]
vamos a hacer honestos un escenario que
todos nos gustaría ver es la caída de
Vladimir Putin es decir que su régimen
colapse a fin de cuentas Esta es una de
las principales razones detrás del
régimen de sanciones de occidente poner
a las élites rusas en contra del Gran
líder por eso hablamos de un aislamiento
que va muchísimo más allá del comercio
el objetivo es llegar al corazón de los
rusos por ejemplo Hace cuatro años Rusia
organizaba el mundial de fútbol sin
embargo en el mundial de fútbol de este
año que se celebra en Qatar Rusia ni
siquiera puede participar y no puede
porque no le dejan sin embargo el propio
Putin también está empezando a jugar
demasiado con las emociones de su pueblo
atentos la llamada filas de Putin
alimenta la ira a las protestas y la
violencia de los rusos para que os
hagáis una idea según la revista Forbes
más de 700.000 rusos abandonaron el país
en tan solo las dos semanas siguientes
al anuncio de la movilización y diréis
podemos viernes de estos números o son
propa pues lo cierto es que es
relativamente fácil hacer un recuento
más o menos objetivo basta con sumar las
cifras que dan los países de acogida por
supuesto puede haber algún error pero en
principio parece razonable pensar que
cientos de miles de rusos están
escapando de los reclutadores también
hemos visto todo tipo de protestas en la
calle y de quejas por internet pensadlo
bien una cosa es apoyar una guerra que
ves por la televisión acompañada de la
conveniente propaganda y otra muy
distinta es apoyar una guerra donde tú
vas a combatir al frente
[Música]
y lo cierto Es que no es la primera vez
que esto pasa en Rusia habéis oído bien
si miramos un poco de historia veremos
que antes de Ucrania Rusia ha hecho dos
grandes movilizaciones una fue en la
Segunda Guerra Mundial y otra en la
primera durante la Segunda Guerra
Mundial casi todos los rusos entendieron
que tenían que luchar a fin de cuentas
estaban siendo invadidos por la Alemania
nazi sin embargo la movilización de la
Primera Guerra Mundial terminó realmente
mal para el kremlin en este caso se
desató todo un motín militar y hablamos
de un motín que fue clave para la caída
de los zares y el ascenso de los
bolcheviques habéis oído bien en el
vídeo de hoy vamos a ver con todo
detalle que sucedió en Rusia en 1917 Así
que la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos Es
que tienen común la Rusia de los zares
con la Rusia de Putin podría la Guerra
de Ucrania provocar un colapso del
régimen como el que propició las
revoluciones de 1917 hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
hablando de imperios habéis oído decir
que china puede estar a punto de sufrir
una enorme crisis económica y financiera
me ha puesto a que casi todos habréis
oído hablar de la burbuja inmobiliaria y
de las ciudades fantasma en China Pues
bien Ahora este problema amenaza con
causar toda una enorme crisis financiera
pero hasta qué punto la economía china
está en problemas como piensa el
gobierno de Pink darle la vuelta a esta
situación para saber más sobre esta
cuestión No te pierdas el vídeo que le
hemos dedicado a este tema en si lo
hubiera sabido el canal de información
financiera demuto activos os dejo el
enlace en la descripción y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la revolución de febrero
no no nos hemos equivocado hemos dicho
la revolución de febrero y no la
revolución de octubre que es la que
todos conocemos y es que meses Antes de
que los comunistas hicieran con el
control de Rusia se produjo otra
Revolución esta vez era una Revolución
liberal y diréis Pero por qué pues vamos
a verlo el Imperio ruso atravesaba por
una etapa de profunda decadencia a
principios del siglo XX las reformas
para modernizar Rusia y acercarse a
otras potencias europeas habían quedado
truncadas con el asesinato del zar
Alejandro II su sucesor Alejandro III
volvió la vieja fórmula que emplearon
los romanoff durante tres siglos una
mezcla de religión ortodoxa autocracia y
nacionalismo es decir la clásica
ideología de la Rusia zarista basada en
la lealtad hacia el gobierno de la
dinastía romanov La Fe religiosa
tradicional y la glorificación de la
madre patria
peor aún lo hizo el zar ni con la II
primero emprendió una guerra con Japón
que condujo a una de las mayores
humillaciones históricas de Rusia el
descontento provocó la revolución de
1905 en la que el zar tuvo que hacer
algunas concesiones simbólicas como la
creación de la duma una asamblea
parlamentaria que en aquel momento
carecía de poder real pero es que más
tarde en 1914 se erigió en el defensor
del nacionalismo serbio e involucró a
Rusia en la gran guerra es decir la
Primera Guerra Mundial Rusia se enfrentó
en la guerra Alemania y al imperio
austrohúngaro y a pesar de las victorias
iniciales de los austriacos el ejército
ruso fue aplastado por Alemania causando
miles de bajas el frente se estabilizó y
el zar Nicolás II partió al frente a
dirigir a sus tropas a pesar del éxito
de la ofensiva bruceloff cimentada sobre
medio millón de bajas pronto Rusia se
vio acorralada de nuevo para sufrir
derrota tras derrota 1917 convenció en
Rusia Con mucho frío y una gran
inflación la mayoría de los obreros de
San Petersburgo tenían que elegir entre
pasar frío o tratar calentarse a Costa
de pasar hambre ya que un huevo costaba
4 veces más que en 1914 y la mantequilla
5 veces más además de la escasez de
alimentos y de la extrema pobreza un
millón 700.000 rusos habían muerto en la
guerra otros 5 millones estaban herido y
un millón 500.000 habían sido hechos
prisioneros y otros tantos habían
desertado del ejército como os podéis
imaginar las protestas eran continuas y
cada vez más multitudinarias hasta que
finalmente tuvo lugar la revolución de
febrero y no no estamos hablando Todavía
de la Revolución bolchevique hablamos de
la que tuvo lugar meses antes esta no
era una Revolución comunista sino una
Revolución liberal
en este caso el zar intentó sofocar la
revuelta por la fuerza pero las
diferentes guarniciones de San
Petersburgo se sublevaron y
desobedecieron las órdenes recibidas una
semana después digo la segundo abdicó el
zarismo fue reemplazado por un gobierno
provisional que decidió continuar con la
participación de Rusia en la gran guerra
respetando las alianzas internacionales
en las que el zar Nicolás II había
involucrado al país el programa de este
gobierno es que era provisional y muy
débil en las calles cada vez Estaba
volviendo más poderoso el soviet de
petrogrado una especie de consejo de
trabajadores y soldados de la que
entonces era la capital rusa es decir la
actual San Petersburgo mientras los
revolucionarios más radicales es decir
los bolcheviques se hacían poco a poco
más fuertes en el show de petrogrado el
gobierno provisional ruso estaba
integrado por políticos liberales
socialistas moderados y un socio
revolucionario como Alexander kerensky
que enseguida se convirtió en ministro
de guerra y de Marina al frente del
ejército kerenski se la jugó aún todo o
nada En qué consistió este ataque a la
desesperada para evitar la derrota en la
guerra Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
la ofensiva kerensky
[Música]
Rusia se había comprometido con sus
aliados a lanzar una ofensiva para
dividir la atención del enemigo alemán y
austrohúngaro en dos frentes pero el
ejército ruso no atravesaba precisamente
por su mejor momento la disciplina había
caído enormemente tras la abdicación del
zar como os podéis imaginar además La
tropa desconfiaba de los mandos debido a
la enorme cantidad de bajas sufridas por
el ejército ruso En aquel momento todas
estas bajas tenían además dos
consecuencias fundamentales para Rusia
primero que aunque los soldados seguían
siendo fundamentalmente de origen
campesino los últimos reclutamientos de
1916 habían comenzado a incluir a
hombres de mediana edad y segundo y lo
más importante Aún es que los nuevos
reclutas se enviaban al frente con una
instrucción menor que la de sus
predecesores conclusión Pues que harán
Carne de cañón o son esta historia
exacto no vamos a decir que la historia
se está repitiendo pero está claro que
hay unos cuantos paralelismos las nuevas
tropas de Putin sufrirán mucho en
Ucrania ya que básicamente No tendrán
entrenamiento según la inteligencia del
Reino Unido en 1917 esta falta de
preparación también afectaba
especialmente en los grados bajos del
escalafón es decir los sargentos de todo
esto eran conscientes Los Altos
oficiales que se quejaban de la escasa
capacidad de los nuevos mandos y de la
poca calidad de los refuerzos recibidos
pero esperad un momento porque aún
tenían que lidiar con un problema aún
mayor
los recién llegados al frente se oponían
a la guerra y pensaban que el fracaso de
la ofensiva kanensky hundiría al
gobierno provisional y serviría para
alcanzar más rápidamente La Paz algo
parecido a lo que pueden estar pensando
ahora muchos rusos combatiendo en
Ucrania la propaganda rusa ha vendido la
invasión de Ucrania como una operación
del ejército para luchar contra el
fascismo del país vecino los rusos Ven
por tanto la intervención en Ucrania
como algo completamente ajeno al día a
día de su propio país a principios del
siglo XX los rusos tampoco consideraban
la Primera Guerra Mundial como una
cuestión existencial es algo que tienen
en común la rusa de los zares y la Rusia
de Putin la falta de una ideología Clara
a la hora de dirigir el país está claro
que los ucranianos luchan para
sobrevivir como país quieren ser
independientes y tener su propio sistema
político democrático parecido de la
Unión Europea Pero por qué luchan los
rusos A diferencia de manera soviética
actualmente el kremlin carece de una
ideología tan Clara y sólida como el
comunismo dicho de otra forma que los
soviéticos querían extender su
Revolución por todos los rincones del
planeta sin embargo el puntillismo no
tiene esas aspiraciones internacionales
nada más lejos de la realidad el
planteamiento de Putin es puramente
nacionalistas Es decir que se basa en la
idea de que no hay nada mejor en esta
vida que ser ruso esa vieja noción
romántica del nacionalismo que ya
explotan los zares en su momento sin
embargo mis queridos amigos y amigas de
visualpolitik en pleno Siglo XXI Esto no
es motivación suficiente para ir al
frente y menos en las condiciones en las
que el kremlin está enviando a sus
hombres la indignación aumenta a medida
que los reclutas rusos son lanzados a la
batalla sin entrenamiento ni equipo la
ofensiva querensky fracasó cuando los
soldados rusos se amotinaron y
rechazaron seguir combatiendo esta sin
subordinaciones dieron tiempo Alemania
para reforzar el frente y lanzar una
contraofensiva En otras palabras que
lejos de reforzar la moral del ejército
ruso la ofensiva y probó que la moral de
sus tropas estaba por los suelos y que
ninguna de sus generales podía contar
con que los soldados Bajo su mando
ejecutarse en las órdenes que les
diesese
[Música]
los problemas se acumulaban para el
gobierno provisional ruso que para
entonces llevaba varios meses sujeto por
alfileres gracias a la brillante idea
que había tenido el enemigo alemán y os
preguntaréis Pero qué idea era esa pues
alguien debió pensar vamos a ver si
Lenin quiere negociar la paz con
nosotros Porque no le sacamos de su
exilio en Suiza y le metemos en Rusia y
como decimos en visualpolitik dicho y
hecho en abril de 1917 se produjo un
viaje en tren crucial para la historia
Vladimir Lenin viajó de Zurich a San
Petersburgo recorriendo más de 3.000
kilómetros algo imposible en plena
Primera Guerra Mundial sin la ayuda
alemana pero las ambiciones de Berlín
rápidamente se vieron recompensadas
porque a su llegada San Petersburgo
Lenin anunció las famosas tesis de abril
es decir que prometió que si los
bolcheviques llegaban al gobierno Rusia
saldría de la guerra darían la tierra
los campesinos y el poder al
proletariado este fue el momento del
histórico lema de todo el poder para los
soviet es lo que tiene recurrir a un
agitador de las masas como Lenin que
sabía perfectamente lo que querían
escuchar los rusos de a pie y aquí es
donde viene una diferencia importante
con la Rusia de Putin ahora mismo no hay
un líder ni una figura de referencia que
aglutina el descontento de los rusos con
la guerra y no parece que nadie esté
apoyando a la oposición rusa al menos no
con la misma intensidad y sobre todo con
los mismos rublos con los que la
Alemania del Kaiser colocó en manos de
los bolcheviques hace un siglo Edward
Bernstein un político alemán que está
considerado como uno de los padres de la
sociedad democracia aseguraba que el
gobierno alemán financió a los
bolcheviques entre 1917 y 1918 con cerca
de 10 millones de dólares de la época
para ayudarlos a tomar el poder hoy en
día el apoyo occidental se está
concentrando en sostener al gobierno de
Ucrania pero recordemos que apoyar la
oposición rusa fue muy efectivo hacia un
siglo y diréis cómo se hicieron los
bolcheviques con el poder pues atentos
la revolución de octubre
[Música]
después del fracaso de la ofensiva el
gobierno provisional dirigido por
keremsky intentó reorganizar el ejército
colocando al laver corniloff al frente
este general harto del caos en el que
estaba asumido Rusia intentó implantar
una dictadura militar Y para ello lanzó
un golpe de estado contra revolucionario
como os podéis imaginar cornilov fracasó
Pero no por la oposición del gobierno
provisional de krenski que a estas
alturas ya no tenía poder sobre nadie
por qué Porque nadie creía en Su
autoridad cornilo se tomó con los oviets
y fundamentalmente con la resistencia de
los bolcheviques este golpe fallido
reforzó la pérdida de autoridad de los
oficiales ante las tropas que les veían
como simple representantes de un poder
autoritario con el que había que acabar
y esto también supuso el espaldarazo
definitivo de los bolcheviques es decir
los revolucionarios más radicales que
garantizaban que no habría vuelta atrás
al zarismo los bolcheviques exigieron al
gobierno libertad de movimientos para la
guardia roja hablamos de destacamentos
los obreros que estaban armados y que
serían decisivos para el éxito de la
Revolución los bolcheviques aunaron a
los trabajadores y soldados de
petrogrado Es decir de San Petersburgo
para derrocar al gobierno provisional se
formó un nuevo ejército dirigido por
Lenin que tomó el control del campo y
creó la Checa una organización de
inteligencia política y militar dirigida
a aplastar cualquier tipo de disidencia
Además tal y como habían prometido Rusia
firmó la paz con Alemania y además un
acuerdo que supuso una independencia
efímera para la República de Ucrania
pero eso es otra historia
[Música]
El Triunfo de la revolución de octubre
dio comienzo a una guerra civil de 6
años se enfrentaron el ejército rojo y
el ejército blanco que agrupaba a todos
los enemigos de la Revolución
bolchevique el conflicto devastó por
completo a Rusia y culminó de una vez
por todas el triunfo del Poder soviético
y diréis qué pasa en la Rusia de hoy en
la Rusia de Vladimir Putin pues
posiblemente hoy en día no se dan las
condiciones para una Revolución que
derroque al Gran líder dicho de otra
forma tienes ahora el principal líder de
la oposición anti Putin Alex Sin embargo
a diferencia de Lenin naval ni no está
en el exilio sino en una cárcel rusa
vamos que parece un poco difícil poderle
apoyar desde occidente aún así los
aliados de naval ni continúan moviéndose
por ejemplo este mensaje lo lanzó a
principios de octubre nada menos que
ivans que es la mano derecha de navalni
y que sí que se encuentra actualmente en
el exilio atentos
y bueno el problema El problema para la
revolución es que las cosas han cambiado
mucho desde los tiempos de Lenin el
control sobre la sociedad sobre las
comunicaciones de los diside es mucho
mayor que el que se podía tener hace un
siglo y otra de las ventajas de Vladimir
Putin es que no está tan desgastado ante
la población rusa fundamentalmente
porque la propaganda del régimen en
realidad no trata de convencer a los
rusos de que el mundo necesita Putin al
menos no al mismo estilo que por ejemplo
el chavismo ensalzaba la figura Diego
Chávez es muy diferente veréis la
popularidad de Putin siempre ha
descansado en la apatía de la gente Algo
similar a lo vivido durante la época
zarista hace tiempo que los rusos
entienden que la política es cosa de
Putin y sus amigos y procuran no opinar
ahora bien como la Guerra de Ucrania
está lejos de ir como esperaba el
kremlin el descontento está produciendo
movimientos que hace meses eran
totalmente inesperados Cuál es pues
ahora mismo los vamos a ver
[Música]
la ofensiva Putin
el gran minat Doblado su apuesta con la
movilización parcial y como os podéis
imaginar esta no sale gratis como todo
el mundo entiende salvo el kadiró eso
dirá al frente en general no le hace
gracia al ciudadano de a pie al menos si
la preparación adecuada además para
cuando se anunció el llamamiento a filas
ya habían transcurrido siete meses de
guerra más de medio año en el que muchos
han visto como sus compatriotas
regresaban heridos o incluso en un
féretro y de hecho algunos ya se han
atrevido a levantar la voz contra Cómo
se está llevando a cabo la movilización
y este es el caso del presidente de la
república de dragonstant la República de
Pakistán es una región rusa que hace
frontera con Georgia y azerbaiyán y que
está orillas del mar caspio Pues bien el
gobernador de esta región es este señor
que veis en pantalla ser gay melicoff
sergi no es ningún enemigo de Putin ni
muchísimo menos tiene una carrera
militar de altos vuelos es más ha
llegado a ser un alto Rango en la
guardia Nacional de Putin ahora es la
máxima autoridad en esta región tan
específica de Rusia sin embargo Mirad lo
que ha dicho sobre oficiales de
reclutamiento de las fuerzas armadas
atentos
principios pensando así la que están es
una de las regiones más pobres de Rusia
además tiene una población de poco más
de 3 millones de habitantes melikov
tiene miedo de que muchos de estos miles
de jóvenes que están siendo reclutados
para el frente no vuelven Y dejen a ser
República aún más envejecida de lo que
ya está pero esperad un momento porque
el descontento con Cómo se ha organizado
la movilización parcial de Rusia va
mucho más allá de un problema anecdótico
en el dakenstein
[Música]
es una tendencia constatada las regiones
más pobres y marginadas de Rusia son las
que están arriesgando más en la Guerra
de Ucrania las minorías étnicas de Rusia
lamentan la guerra en Ucrania hay
grandes incógnitas sobre las bajas rusas
porque ya sabéis que en Las Guerras la
transparencia es la primera víctima Pero
hay investigaciones que señalan
claramente que los soldados procedentes
de las regiones más pobres de la
federación Como por ejemplo la República
de buriatia en la frontera como mongolia
o el propio de agestan están
representados de manera
desproporcionadamente alta entre Las
bajas rusas de igual modo apenas está
muriendo en la guerra los jóvenes
procedentes de las grandes capitales del
país sin duda un movimiento inteligente
por parte de Putin porque mantener la
lealtad de las élites le mantendrá en el
poder la revoluciones del siglo XX se
extendían de las ciudades a la periferia
y nunca ha sido al revés esta vez no
habrá soviets de petrogrado pero ojo con
irritar a la repúblicas periféricas Así
que la pregunta que ahora nos hacemos Es
creéis que en algún momento puede caer
el régimen de Putin o pensáis que su
control sobre la sociedad Rusia
incluyendo la periferia es tan grande
que una Revolución es completamente
imposible podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones y dadle a la
campanita para que os llegue una
notificación al teléfono móvil si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]